the biggest drug cartels in the world
get together and buy up all the media
and all the politicians and force all
the people in the world stay locked in
their homes and people can only come out
if they take the cartels drugs and keep
taking them over and over
I threw the script away I mean who is
going to believe that crazy idea here
are four headlines that appeared
immediately after on Sunday yesterday
Rolling Stone Woody Harrelson spreads
anti-vaxx conspiracies Daily Beast Woody
Harrelson spews anti-vax conspiracies in
Rambling SNL Monologue it's almost like
they coordinate this stuff literally
prove his point right in front you guys
get this once they start coordinating
this stuff I think we can refer to the
mainstream media as a cartel they work
in conjunction to take out their enemies